probably hurt his opinion editor of the
Washington Times he joins us tonight
with reaction to this Charlie thanks so
much for coming on did you was did you
find it refreshing to hear someone
whether you agree with him or not talk
about things that might actually Define
Our grandchildren's Lives
well well like you said a minute ago you
know he's talking about things that
nobody else is talking about and of
course you know when was the last time
somebody was doing that well that was
when Donald Trump in 2016 was running
the first time he was talking about
things that nobody else was talking
about in Washington and we I think you
know you and I agree these people are
desperate to ignore these issues and
ignore these topics and as you say you
know whatever you think of Donald Trump
he's a very smart businessman and he's
probably the shrewdest political
Observer that we've seen in this country
on the political stage uh in a lifetime
and uh when he you know and I thought it
was so interesting the degree to which
he focused on foreign policy and
identified that the great threat for us
is indeed foreign policy and when you
look at the fact that in two years since
he's been gone uh the bite
Administration is given away our energy
Independence it has launched a whole new
war it has eroded our standing in the
world to the point that China and Russia
have aligned against us and they're
frittering away the U.S dollar and all
of this is from Joe Biden who for 50
years has been the reigning foreign
policy expert in Washington the whole
reason he got picked as vice president
is because he was the biggest genius at
foreign policy that that Washington ever
produced and then you have this guy
who's a real estate reality TV Mogul who
walks in and calls their BS at every
turn and it turns out he's right about
all of it he's he's the Donald Trump is
the best Statesman when it comes to
foreign policy especially that that
we've had in in decades
we're closer to nuclear Annihilation
than any time in the history of nuclear
weapons right now and all the Liberals
are ignoring it and it falls to Trump to
remind us of that
it's I've never seen anything crazier
than this uh Charlie heard appreciate
your perspective as always thank you
good to see you bud
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight